what's up guys we're still in the
theater we just got done watching
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 just watch
the two post credit scenes here with all
my favorite people
Wendy John Greg John look at the camera
certainly a movie Greg what'd you think
of it
John what did you think of it it's
better than quarter Mania Wendy was it
better than quantumania
there you go it was uh it was better
than Hitman Quantum media I think
everybody in the audience tonight really
loved the movie
um I I heard a lot of people crying
right
[Music]
did you cry
oh he cried he cried do you have a word
to describe it
exactly there you go yeah well we're
gonna oh wait
it's exactly
I would say the ending to me was not
anything that I thought it was going to
be but it was shut up exactly exactly
what it shows
the ending was exactly what I thought
what it should be and it's not what I
thought it was actually I thought it was
going to go a lot in a very different
direction but I'm glad it went this way
because it was perfect the ending was
perfect
for me for me uh this isn't a review but
there is a part of it that I didn't like
it's but it's like a very personal thing
of mine and and no one else I've talked
to has a problem with it so far so I
think a lot of fans are gonna love this
movie it's definitely the best for
Marvel in years like for sure and it's
an awesome ride and it's the Guardians
of the Galaxy it's freaking you love
watching them on screen it's fun it was
a great movie it was a great movie and
um
best in Phase five probably the best
from phase four as well I think it's the
best for Marvel in a long time
yeah full review out tomorrow uh 10 a.m
Pacific time I'll dive into that one
aspect that I didn't like again it's
very personal to me I think a lot of
fans aren't going to care about it at
all or might actually really really like
it might be a really cool thing
um it's intense it's super intense it
does pull out your heartstrings
um
can't say too much but
I mean the Roaring Applause for this
movie and it seemed like everybody
really loved it and there's this guy
again but uh yeah it was great it it
really was it was it was fantastic so
I'll catch you guys tomorrow in my
review I dare you to throw popcorn into
the crowd okay
foreign
[Music]